the big news today is that Donald Trump
has been elected president oh yeah this
is gonna be great okay that's that's
Tony one of our cameramen at Tony you're
happy Trump was elected president huh
hey you're darn tootin I am now that
Trump's president you got to hold up
your end of our bet
okay I'm sorry Tony I do not remember
any bet with you you said you was so
sure that Hillary was going to win that
if Trump won you let me show my sexy
dinosaur drawings on TV
now I remember now I remember yeah I
told Tony that if Trump won he could
show his sexy dinosaur drawings on TV
Tony I thought you were kidding
ladies and gentlemen something that all
Americans can enjoy regardless of your
political political politics sexy
dinosaur drawings by me Tony sexy
dinosaur number one that's a sexy
dinosaur I'd like to try Sarah bottom
that Triceratops and you know she's
horny you see the horns we get it yeah
sexy dinosaur number two sexy Allosaurus
I'd like to give you a sore ass okay
okay and one more one more and then
another one is it getting hot in here if
so we don't matter to this sexy
Stegosaurus because the plates on our
back and tail help with temperature
regulation that's just a scientific fact
lastly
lastly I give you the sexiest taco soup
kiss you ever seen that's right it's a
prehistoric 50-foot long ancestor or the
crocodile all right thank you vector
time to diddle that crocodilia night we
got Cretaceous why don't you create this
your sexy piece you're welcome welcome
America let the healing begin
[Applause]
you